you guys a couple nice you didn't just
get a white guy you got a white guy what
do you do for a living you're a manager
at a retail store where do you work you
know what's crazy is I didn't think you
would get wider and then you said I
manage a Walmart I mean if you going to
go lean in you know what I mean don't
date some [__] independent rapper you
could have got a black guy for that you
what I'mma date a white guy so let me
date a white guy how did you guys meet
dating app I assumed I knew you guys
didn't meet in real life there's no way
she shops at your Walmart you know what
I mean it's just not possible that she
would shop at your Walmart and be like
that guy with the V I'm going to give
him some [__] it's not going to happen